vient alors le désir comme vous êtes
quelqu'un qui dit essayer de dire en
tous les cas la vérité je vais vous
faire une interview mensonge tomber
c'est le principe de l'interview
mensonge
hélas vous allez répondre sans dire la
vérité s'appelait la table tiberi avant
alors est-ce que vous avez déjà détourné
de l'argent public
non oui il faut dire oui pardon oui fils
je vous ai déjà frauder le fisc
oui souvent mais moi j'ai jamais fraudé
le fisc
est ce que vous regrettez que jean marie
le pen ait disparu du paysage sonore aux
français oui voilà est ce que vous
sentez proche de mitterrand quand vous
apprenez qu'il a été décoré de la
francisque par le maréchal pétain
et qui l'a gardé longtemps après la
guerre des liens d'amitié avec bousquet
non mais ni terran a été un résistant à
partir de 41 et il a vraiment pris des
risques d argent gelé revenu en france
et donc je crois que ceux qui veulent
donner des leçons il faut d'abord qu'ils
regardent eux mêmes elle a été la
hauteur de leurs propres engagements
dans certains combats vous arrivez pas
mentir là j'ai du mal parfois à lui il y
arrivait bien pourtant
est ce que vous êtes toujours antisémite
harlem désir mais on peut pas répondre
aux joueurs c'est la première fois
moi j'ai vu quand même ici des
communismes expliqué que magna était un
génial
je vous écoute alors est ce que vous
êtes toujours antisémite c'est
impossible pour moi je suis passé je
vous ai déjà couché pour du boulot
bien sûr est ce que c'est vrai que vos
collaboratrice sont victimes de
harcèlement sexuel tous les jours ou
baiser sans capote vous toute façon je
suis d'un principe fréquenter les boîtes
échangistes toujours vous souvenez
et alors seulement combien de même plus
tard par jour en ce moment mais là on
peut pas répondre par oui ou par non à
donner un chiffre
justin fu chi puisque ce sera
l'interview mangez jamais plus de 2,3 à
monsieur colonna se dit [ __ ] il aurait
dit - 2 - 3 je partais est ce que vous
êtes pour l'ecstasy en vente libre est
bien entendu et l'animal